Film Courage: When did you read your first
screenwriting book and which one was it?
Adam William Ward, Actor/Filmmaker: Oh...my
first one?
I think my first book was actually Save The
Cat [Author Blake Snyder], which was a really
good book and it was about outlining.
If anybody wants to be a filmmaker, I would
suggest that book (Save The Cat).
If you want to be a filmmaker it lays out
structure really well.
Not everything has to be formulaic but almost
everything has been done at this point.
So even when I’m making now where I’m
making this book Catch The White Tiger [Catch
the White Tiger: How I Achieved the American
Dream With $28 by Authors Tony Assali and
Michael Ashley], it’s a biopic so I go and
watch all biopics.
What kind of biopic do I want to make?
THE GULF OF WALL STREET is very different from
THE FLOUNDER, you know what I mean?
So the blueprint is there in a way.
That helps you make a blueprint that book
[Save The Cat].
That’s a very helpful book but I feel like
watching movies was the most helpful for me.
My brother who is my writing partner will
send me script and be like “Here.”
He just sent me three scripts yesterday of
all of these biopics.
I’d rather watch the movies because I’m
very much...I know that a script can change
so much compared to making a movie.
When you’re seeing it in the movie it might
be improv, it might be whatever.
But that could still be a script.
Maybe it wasn’t a script, maybe it wasn’t
a script but it could have been a script if
you wrote it that way.
So I kind of like watching the final product
more than reading the script in the sense
of learning when it comes to GREATFELLAS reading
the script or watching the movie I’d rather
watch the movie and analyze that.
But my brother is the opposite so it just
depends on how you learn.
And with the Internet you can get your hands
on so many scripts and learn so much.
You can read the script for GREATFELLAS.
When I was a young kid you could never get
your hands on a script like that unless you
went to the American Film Institute or one
of these big film schools that have those
kind of scripts and then you could read it
and learn from it.
Nowadays people can learn so easily with the
Internet.
It’s a great thing if you want to learn.
Film Courage: What three scripts did he send
you?
Adam: He sent me THE GULF OF WALLSTREET.
He sent me THE FLOUNDER and he sent me GREATFELLAS
(that’s why I brought them all up).
I think I opened THE GULF OF WALLSTREET and read
the first couple of pages and was like “Ahhh.
I’ll watch the movie.”
I don’t know if I’ll read it or not.
But he’s read it and he’s my writing partner.
I would like to read them just for fun but
I feel like now is not the time.
For me I get more from a movie than a script
because I’m a filmmaker.
He’s a script writer.
He wants to just be a script writer (my brother
Charlie Ward).
I want to be a filmmaker and an actor.
I write scripts out of necessity, I don’t
really want to write scripts.
I write them because I don’t have a script.
I’ve been blessed with the fact that at
least I know structure well and I’ve watched...I
used to watch two or three movies a day when
I was a kid and I moved from Philadelphia
when I was a kid to Roseburg, OR and Glide,
OR when I was 12 years old and there was nothing
to do.
I went from the mall and the skating rink
to the like okay there’s a lot of trees
around, there’s nothing to do.
The first neighbor is like a mile away.
I would just watch movies like crazy, I’d
watch two or three movies a day.
All of my free time was spent watching movies
or running around.
I’ve heard it before that you have to spend
10,000 hours on your craft to really be a
master at it.
Well I easily watched over 10,000 hours of
movies to be where I’ve gotten.
And honestly that’s what makes you an artist
in a way because the things that used to shock
me and impress me and intrigue me as a kid
watching movies are different than what I
do now because I’ve seen so many of them
so it’s different.
You can think back to the time when it did
but ultimately now I have so much more of
a library in my head of movies that now you’re
competing with all of those as to where if
I only saw seven movies this movie is amazing
but it is only competing with six but if you
watch 10,000 hours or whatever now I’ve
seen GODFATHER and GREATFELLAS and they are
both crime movies and now they are competing
against each other.
Some people these days say “This is my favorite
movie.”
But they’ve never seen all of these movies
in the 70’s and 80’s and I’m thinking
but yeah you don’t really know your craft.
You have to spend the time to watch all of
those movies and really learn your craft.
Film Courage: Would you say that Charlie is
good at one part of screenwriting and you’re
good at the other?
I mean how do you work together with a partner?
How is that?
Adam: With Seth it was different.
So Seth Hymes and me wrote WALLY GOT WASTED.
Charle is writing this new movie with me.
two very different writing partners for me.
Seth really wanted to put the words on the
page.
And so I would basically do the outline and
he would go off and write by himself and then
come bring it back to me and then I’d read
it and make all of these corrections on the
page and be like this scene doesn’t hit
this moment.
I need this moment.
This is like...(as an example) this is the
low of the movie.
These guys have to turn on each other.
I need a good monologue here of him turning
on him and no hope you know.”
And that was one of the scenes that Seth couldn’t
end up doing on is own but most of them I’d
give different notes and he would go and make
funny moments and do certain things that he
would change and write it.
And then the low of the movie in WALLY GOT
WASTED there on a cliffside overlooking all
of Los Angeles he could never get that scene
so I was like “Okay, I’ll write it.”
So then I wrote that scene and the joke is
in her mind but the jokes and the other scene
are his.
It’s nice to write in a group.
ATTACHMENT THEORY I wrote on my own by myself.
But WALLY GOT WASTED was with Seth and then
this new one is with my brother.
My brother and me have been writing scripts
since I was a child so we have very much shorthand
with each other of thinking a lot of the same
things and stuff like that.
Funny I have not found anybody that we like
to write words on the page together.
It’s kind of like he goes off and writes,
I go off and write, and we come together.
I’ve yet to find somebody who likes to write
in the room together but that would be interesting.
It would be a dream come true in a way.
It would be fun.
And I’ve done that with my brother.
PAROLE OFFICERS we did together.
I acted out all of the characters in the living
room and he sat there and would type.
So I’m like living the characters and saying
what they would say and then he’s like writing
them down.
It was a very different process with PAROLE
OFFICERS.
But most of them had people who wanted to
write alone.
They want their creativity to be quiet and
all of that kind of stuff so I was just different.